[Music]
my name is Velma Dinkley and I've
decided to finally share the bone Tone
event that drove me to assemble the
greatest team of spooky mystery solvers
ever this is my story told my way
I'm not dissing her she has
and it starts with a murder
[Music]
if I can't convince people I didn't kill
Brenda I'm going to be arrested I know
but I also know how to find out who did
Kill Brenda I think it has something to
do with drugs which I hate
okay Fred do I know you it's Velma from
school I have a disease where I can't
recognize people who aren't hot is it
called rudeness I have an
okay Daphne I need a favor why would I
do that we're not friends anymore we're
Nemesis Nemesis that's why
maybe it's one of those doors where you
push in a brick and it opens
I have a plan I love Danger
[Music]
you might have more success with this if
you went in just a little less judgy
okay Daphne I'm the brains of this
operation you're just the look style and
effortless charm
we do make a good team don't we
[Music]
in this day and age you can't speculate
about someone's sexuality unless they're
famous or Peppermint Patty
[Applause]
tonight
the rules feel a bit muddy muddy oh
sorry I'm not a drunk on the verge of
losing custody like every other woman
solving murders these days
[Music]
all our classmates are idiots so let's
assume they're high you know what 420 is
right
um yeah it's code for adults who still
watch cartoons
[Music]
thank you